it's time to babble the [ __ ] on live
from the Jon Lovitz podcast theatre it's
in Hollywood babble-on
with your hosts Kevin Smith and Ralph
Garman
I feel like Ralph all of a sudden whoa
this is really weird man I don't know if
I was told to go and he'd follow he's in
costume and I haven't seen it and he
wanted to surprise me
[Music]
[ __ ] dick unbelievable it is Saturday
night in Hollywood so let's battle the
[ __ ] on
let's see how we handle this I'm Kevin
Smith
I'm Kevin Smith
man had I known I would have worn a
leather jacket or just something I
counted on you wearing this I was this
close dude I almost wore the hoodie from
the southwest incident I was going to
play keV Smith from two years ago right
but I wore this thank God otherwise that
would have been a bit of a buzzkill
this is actually a pretty good look for
us yeah yeah very comfy I can see why
you do it
I just oh my god for those listening at
home Ralph is dressed like a really
great director
there's my square cz outfit this is what
I would look like then though you're
haunting me right on stage like every
time I look over I'm like oh that's what
it could be I do feel like James Brolin
wait like pee-wee Herman in the movie
about his life paging mr. Herman mr.
pee-wee Herman happy Halloween Halloween
sir and happy Halloween to all of you
and yeah thanks for coming out
it's a special edition of Halloween boo
belong where you belong
I've been wearing glasses in a while
take them off just lose them it's like a
Clark Kent Superman thing hey good I
think we're all right yeah now that way
people could tell us apart
yes thanks for coming out in the special
Halloween Babylon we are having a little
contest where'd you get the Jersey I had
your your assistant smuggle it out of
your house for me [ __ ] magnet yeah I
told her I'd hire her if you fired her
over this fair enough she's good ya know
everybody was in on it and I appreciate
the help of all your your nearest and
dearest right down to the etnies I'm you
son Lenny's got jean shorts I'm adorable
you are a thinner healthier version of
me it's depressing the hardest part was
smoking a bale of weed today that was
that was exhausting I don't know you do
it every day but somebody's got to do it
yeah I know it is the Halloween special
edition of Babylon and we are going to
give out some prizes either
earlier or later on on the show to the
best guy in best girl costume so thanks
for you folks who came dressed up
tonight we appreciate it
very few thank you also some pins you
might wind up winning that's what I want
it to win so badly the prize is the
special Kevin Smith too fat for 40 and
SMAW donations box set thanks to the
people at Shout Factory for this and
what's it got inside well the reason
we're giving this away tonight is it's
the only place you can get the Hollywood
babble-on
DVD is actually a DVD of the show so if
you don't win tonight
and you can buy this box set and get the
Hollywood babble-on
DVD next week we're gonna be in Las
Vegas Nevada for those people who are
gonna be in the region we and we won't
be here so won't be here so come see us
in Vegas if you're gonna be nearby way
to cheer up the crowd next week we're
not gonna be here well maybe they'll all
come to Vegas
it's not that far yeah that's true
nobody wants to take that ride though
Southwest is just a skip and a jump oh
sorry
no luck dry drive it's better it's a
short drive and it's great everyone
likes that as you know we start the show
every week with shout out for people who
came particularly long distances or you
know gee look like is the GI Joe doll
you know nothing little action figure
but from when we were kids the 12-inch
becomes rip Kongfu Griffin he had the
beard just like yours and where it was
kind of real but not the pitch to grow
this in a day off a concentrated hair
growing we do shoutouts where people
can't particularly long distance who are
celebrating special occasions tonight so
we want to give some shoutouts is Jim
Maury here Jim hey Jim how are you sir I
want to give a shout out because they
say is gonna be R tonight and he also
was the one who carved these uh pumpkins
of us tonight from our logo and Jim's
work is also gonna be on NFL this this
Sunday you can check it out you can see
him doing the entire morning show for
the NFL casting check that out 9 a.m.
yes
also speaking of Sunday on Fox Family
Guy this Sunday night does meeting those
you listening because it's Monday but
for you people here I'll be the special
guest star and Family Guy on Sunday
night what are you do you've done voices
before kind of voices feature voice I am
the main character in the episode I'm
the guy yeah we finally gave me a big
meaty role so you're taking over Fox one
show at a time exactly I am after house
on the Family Guy and then
gosh bones I guess jumpin bones oh yeah
I'll be a corpse so a Jim thanks for
coming I appreciate it Chris and Lizzie
from Tasmania you Devils no Chris
Reich's recently convinced Lizzie to
move back to Australia after spending
six years in New York City little did
she know we'd be going to one of the
most isolated spots in the bloody world
yeah Tasmania is kind of isolator isn't
it I was wondering if you could get a
shout out as Adam West and could explain
to the audience what Australians mean
when they say show us your map of Tassie
sure I'd be happy to do we have do we
have a map of Tasmania we can throw up
on the screen there so we can get an
idea what it means when guys say show me
the map of Tassie you see old chum women
who are natural down below always carry
with them a map of Tasmania it's their
pubic hair for thought what do you think
what does that mean email gone like you
might want to dress like me this week I
could I knew I could count on you this
is from Brandon Kay Brandon can you hear
with the Liz and and sin arm raise
doesn't help it's gonna make a little
noise Brandon Kay Barry that's what
we're talking about now bringing are you
Elektra he is look at that he's got the
weapons and everything oh dude yes yes
Brandon is a dude that's a guy that's
this guy yes my ass
I'm excited I saw bearskin Electress
eyes I was like right on man also would
hit the table yeah sexy oh speaking of
wood we forgot the shoutout theme didn't
we
oh sorry about that can we hit that
James better late than never
shoutout Kevin Brown so get your [ __ ]
out
[Music]
not this Kevin Smith Brandon says he
brought Liz and sin with him to babble
virgins to the show these two ladies are
very special to me Brendon Brad writes
Brandon rather I've known them since
high school they've been there for me
through some incredibly tough times
they've now lent them lent me their hand
and shelter when needed but also gave me
endless emotional support over the years
in fact Cindy even went as far as to be
my beard for my parents that's sweet
get out of here so she was just like the
girlfriend and whatnot and you were like
I'm gonna go in the room and feel her
boobies at second face and the parents
are like dude wasn't you dressing like a
lecture a hint to the folks maybe that
boy dressed as a lecture and they were
like sigh oh that's a really funny
[ __ ] comic book joke appear from that
world at all at Holden they're laughing
I wanted to tell them as simple
thank-you from Harrison Ford since Ted
is my favorite voice of yours as far as
mr. Smith goes please let him know that
he can come watch me my partner anytime
not into bears or labels but damn
Kevin's one hot special bear so you've
got an open invitation Wow thank you I
also love your deep sexy creepy voice -
please don't stop the one I just did
yeah the one you could get that's from
Brandon then this is for a Liz and Cindy
from Harrison Ford
[Music]
even a really good friend of random
beard maybe stopping within get a man
hey go through you guys merits and forth
I just want to say for the record it's
not gay if he's dressed like elected and
you're wearing red leather and you're
blind yeah that's right I'm like I'm
Matt Murdoch it's okay if you're blind
you're blind can't you still tell but
that's a [ __ ] and balls in your mouth
there could be a huge [ __ ] you don't
know it's all good in the dark just in
Wilburn is justin in the house that's
put on top oh [ __ ] with authority well
done man
are you a Jedi Knight sir damn straight
alright my fiancee Mary Beth and her
sister Ann will be with me at the show
Justin Wright's singing that is her
sister's first time I was one of you to
give her a shout-out welcome to Harris
Edie win well of course I'd be happy to
oh my goodness man have you met the dude
who looks like the comic book female
character across from you it's amazing
isn't it he's sexy as hell
I do him cuz like this for the living
don't you know welcome to the show
say you're welcome thank you alright
then my goodness
we get emails from around the world
James got an email
[Music]
featuring Kevin's reactions I got a hair
in my mouth
what was it man it's a very gay night
tonight oh yeah hello far it's not gay
on Halloween weekend he had this beard
like I'm dating an Armenian girl like
that old joke what's the sound of pubic
hair makes for hits the floor I guess
that was what's the sound come make oh
stop this emails from Chris asks been a
huge fan of the show on a thank you so
much for giving me a reason to smile and
laugh it's been a while since I could do
either it would make my Halloween
Christmas and New Year's if I could hear
Edwin getting a lap dance from the
special needs girl know there are some
lines even I won't cross and that's one
of them that's like crafting a key to
the gates of that is that's applying
your like for a backstage pass to hell
no I refuse oh my goodness sit right
here why don't you I got some singles
you wanting to you hard change Paul he's
a New Zealand er he made that Kevin
Smith directs the Transformers video for
America cartoon about Jason Statham and
bumblebee sitting at the diner having a
conversation about Chewbacca yeah yeah
he made us another animated film this
one is based on last week conversation
when you're eating the york peppermint
pattie and he said let's do a sketch
where I'm the kid trick-or-treating and
you're the scary clown who answers the
door do you remember that yes you
already did an animated video for us
this is from James Paul which you direct
your eyes on the screen if you would is
a video called little kids Halloween
here we go man so I'm a 10 year old kid
my friends and my you guys go ahead I'm
gonna hang
/ done my real Halloween is like I'm
winded you guys go take a knee
anyway I'm eating my candy okay you're
at the next house and the door opens and
the clown there's your creepy clown
thank you James appreciate the work this
next email is from Nathan quick question
will there be a New Year's Eve show this
year please say yes we'll fly in he
threatens I guess we can announce it now
I guess we're gonna do another New
Year's Eve show we are we're gonna be
here New Year's Eve right here at the
Jon Lovitz podcast theatre so bring it
in with me and rau went so well last
year we had a good time last year was as
a function what I remember was it Justin
Bieber putting out at our show but
didn't he play here on New Year's Eve
there was like some wild act I was
somebody big Lady gaga
no no I thought I was Bieber wasn't the
beeps did he show up in his [ __ ]
Batmobile can you get married in the bat
moment to be in the actual Batmobile
versus taking a Cadillac and making it
sort of the bat knows that what he did
yeah it's called the battle calls it the
battle act yeah that's actually kind of
clever no it's not stop it we'll cover
that in geek news a little bit later
next email comes from Howard and Upper
Darby Pennsylvania right outside my
hometown of Philadelphia recently you
and Kevin talked about having David
Bowie doing his version of Edgar Allen
Poe's the Raven on your Halloween show
yes don't go back on your word or else
I'll be forced to put the worst curse
imaginable on your head which as a
fellow Philadelphia would be that all
your future cheesesteaks come from
Denny's oh that is sad as a threat that
I cannot abide I wanted to fulfill
Howard's request but I looked up the
Raven by Edgar Poe and it's a long [ __ ]
home and Bowie is an impression that
gets old real quick
so what I've done is I chopped it down
just a little taste of the Raven as done
by David Bowie for for Howard you want
to hit that for me James Once Upon a
midnight dreary while I pondered weak
[Music]
[Music]
laughing at my chamber door and the
silken sad uncertain rustling of each
[Music]
[Applause]
he arrives
when with many a flirt and
in the steps of stately Raven of the
saintly days of yore my crest be shorn
and shaven now I said I'll sure no
Craven ghastly grim and ancient Raven
wandering from the nightly show
[Music]
with interpretive dance by Kevin Smith
was that the entire no sir just felt
like it been there's been a very there's
a classic rendition of the Raven done by
James Earl Jones the Simpsons I think
you're number two no wallet that you
very much
Vincent Price is very pissed right now
every week we take a look at scenes and
movies that we cannot believe got past
the creators of the film it started just
the many episodes ago we looked at Back
to the Future 3 where some kid was
pointing at his penis
well the scene was going on and since
I'm taking a look a lot of movies most
recently I guess grease with that weird
dude was stopping sandy at the dude
who's they were like tell me more
there's a dude who was like yeah tell me
more yes it misspent this week
suggestion comes from JP in New Jersey
this proves that even the Masters and it
is Halloween so we're gonna say look at
it from from Alfred Hitchcock even one
of the greats could sometimes miss
something on the screen okay I don't
know I have the clip he says well
actually I found it fits from North by
Northwest there's a scene where Cary
Grant is shot in a cafeteria towards the
end of the movie if you look closely
behind the actors there's a kid extra
who obviously knows what's going to
happen so here is a scene from North by
Northwest I brought my trusty laser
pointer to show you but look for the kid
on the right-hand side who apparently
this is not the first take of this scene
and he is well prepared
yeah isolated for you not putting up
with that [ __ ] and you know [ __ ]
Hitchcock hated Jill oh yeah so we saw
that would just look for her child
have the child killed or cooked and
brought to my dressing room so yeah
sadly every week we take a look at the
oh I forgot the [ __ ] that should not be
jingle to didn't I
man I'm [ __ ] up tonight well I love
that jingle let's do it retrospect shall
we
Michelle can we do that just love that
song every week we take a look at some
people in show business who have
departed who have left us sadly and we
say goodbye to them in a segment we call
Tinseltown sniffs and now another
edition of
[Music]
they will be missed they will indeed
what happened to the other theme song
ma'am that's Hollywood help her how was
it yeah we haven't replaced the [ __ ]
replaced this one yet I heard one online
it was spice mystery man that was really
metal it was like tint all down - we
gotta break it up that sounds horrible
all right we'll work on that this week a
stuntman on the set of Expendables 2
passed away this is horrible news
they're filming in Bulgaria apparently
there was an explosion that was posed to
be used in a scene and the stuntman got
caught up in the explosion actually died
on the set horrible news all right so
wait that's not he was killed he didn't
pass away what do you say it like he
passed I was like oh my god like old age
no he got blown up in an accident forest
alone movie to other performers were
also injured in that explosion
they don't didn't release his name so
the unknown stuntman though we salute
you there is no need for this any more
for anyone to get hurt on a [ __ ] move
now not for a movie there's digital
effects that they could be doing what
not but could you imagine gave your life
to tell it make the return story he's
ridiculous not even to make pretend
story the first one this is the sequel
yeah this is a jean-claude Van Damme
movie now horrible this came to us from
a lot of our British listeners a guy
named Jimmy Savile he was a big deal in
England he was a disc jockey and a TV
presenter he had a show for many years
called Jim affixing where he would take
kids wish letters and fulfill them make
their dreams come true
did you ever see the video the kid who
gets to spend time with Mark Hamill on
the set of Empire I guess it is No yeah
that was part of it that was part of it
this kid wanted to meet Luke Skywalker
and they made it happen so he passed
away this week and also Paul lekha
passed away he was a songwriter and a
producer had a ton of hits that he was
involved with lots of hits in the 60s he
was more importantly the first man ever
to sign REO Speedwagon to a contract so
we have him to thank for our REO
Speedwagon keep on loving him
dude just roll with the changes as I'm
doing the story really he also produced
cat's in the cradle I know which is a
song near and dear to your heart
horrible I mean it's a wonderful song
but it's a horrible song if you're a
parent yeah that's haunting yeah it's
always just a cool your kid but more
importantly he gave us something to sing
at sporting events all over the world
when we want to piss off the opposing
team after they pulled the goalie or
after the the the the pitcher gets
pulled or when somebody strikes out this
is the song that he wrote in 1969 was a
number-one hit
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
god bless and Paul a kid he will be
missed another second we do every week
is called exquisite acting this is when
big-name actors suck on the big screen
it's very entertaining we looked at
Pierce Brosnan he's he sucked in Tappan
or maybe you shouldn't be Ryan O'Neal
Nick Cage is vampire's kiss last week
this week is John Travolta and you have
to go to the classic film Battlefield
Earth to find really Travolta is really
his best form exquisite acting on behalf
of John Travolta he's playing an alien
who was drunk at a bar with Forest
Whitaker Forrest doesn't come off much
better in this scene really quite
frankly but this is a great moment that
was sent to us by Mark Harrison from
Middlesbrough England here is a scene
where John Travolta is complaining about
his position in life from Battlefield
Earth
give them the intro oh sure why not
[Music]
welcome to the world of exquisite acting
with Ralph Garman and Kevin Smith
here's some exquisite acting from John
Travolta from Battlefield Earth some
cushy job more like you could before
while you were still learning how to
spell your name I was being trained to
conquer galaxies
I come galaxy no hug yeah he's the best
this week in new releases this is what
is in theaters everywhere this weekend I
didn't realize until this person sent in
a theme for this we don't have a theme
for new releases for this theme crazy
today and I know he sent this in he
wants to remain anonymous however which
either is a reflection on our show or
the quality of his theme but he says in
his email that the sound design for
masturbation real or simulated is
actually harder than the real thing so
keep that in mind as you hear the jingle
for possibly the last time for our new
segment or our ongoing segment new
releases now playing sexy in theaters
this weekend anonymous the story of
perhaps the fact that Shakespeare didn't
write his own plays that maybe was the
Earl of Oxford who actually wrote his
place it's in theaters right now not
many they they were gonna open it in a
bunch and they kind of opened it and I
think it was under 300 and it opened
kind of week yeah because America said
who the [ __ ] cares yeah The Rum Diary
opened this weekend Johnny Depp it's
another movie that didn't open that well
it did about a million and change last
night I saw it this weekend fifty
million dollar movie how was it I really
liked it a lot I'm a big Johnny Depp fan
and I love Hunter s Thompson was based
on his novel of course if director good
casts very expensive that Amber Heard
holy [ __ ] she is amazing she is so
beautiful she's the blonde woman who
plays his love interest in this was she
in real life though in real life she is
a she was in the Playboy Club she played
the main character in the Playboy Club
the short-lived series the playbook love
she was the blonde Playboy bunny who
else is she who else she she is a
smoking-hot blonde lesbian in real life
really yeah yeah that culture that
culture
what else has she been anyone gonna help
me out anything shoes Pineapple Express
yeah she was in pineapple express to
Seth's girlfriend in the movie yeah
we're he's just like I wanted not marry
me and she's like okay he's like oh I
made a mistake
remember the hot chick who turns into a
zombie to be in a zombie land yes that's
her and she's a lesbian yeah how do you
know that she she came forth
did she yeah I didn't know that Wow did
she's stunning in the film she's
beautiful okay and the fact she's a
lesbian just makes it all that much
hotter yeah a little bit I'm like
interested in her repertoire in time
that who Justin Timberlake action film
that looks like he's gonna do about 10
12 million from yeah not since Taylor
Lautner starred in abduction have I been
as excited about an action stars Justin
Timberlake shooting guns and jumping
over [ __ ] the action stars have
certainly uh shrunk man yes yes to be
like Stallone and [ __ ] Schwarzenegger
or Bruce Willis and now it's Justin
Timberlake and and the little boy who is
the wolf sometimes yes the talking
talking dog from Twilight yeah you don't
need testicles anymore to be an action
star that's the thing you know you have
to eat testicle and Puss in Boots also
open up the week this weekend that's the
big hit of the weekend Antonio Banderas
about 37 to 40 million yeah America
loves it splits my friend wrote the
friend Brian Brian Lynch wrote that he
wrote that yeah yeah the Sandin right
now know if he's the only writer if he's
one of a few but he's on it HBO
headlines this week in keeping with the
holiday all of the stories tonight will
be horrifying just want to let you know
that anyone want to guess what the
number one selling Halloween costume is
this holiday season
not Snooki that's horrifying Charlie
Sheen sir you're correct Charlie Sheen
is the best-selling Halloween cost
this holiday season Sheen masks wigs
winning t-shirts
Charlie's Goddess t-shirts all of that
stuff is selling out according to
retailers across the United States and
Charlie gets a cut of all of that he's
got all of that copywriter I don't know
if I buy that man I was in I've been in
a couple costume stores this week
because the kid wanted costume right and
I saw up many I didn't see like [ __ ]
were there flying off the shelf we are
winning with these costumes there were a
bunch there I don't know if I buy this
this sounds like spin and huh this was
the last Kevin Smith costume in the
store I went to they were flying off the
shelves apparently I saw what did I see
the big costume that I saw every place I
went was [ __ ] Angry Birds really yeah
it was just a big round costume he put
on and [ __ ] I saw one muse wanted to get
one it was a little involved very large
outfit breathalyser and like his head is
here in the window and we blow is his
shirt naturally Charlie is having a good
week however because FX the cable
network just picked up his sitcom anger
management based on the movie starring
Adam Sandler and Jack Nicholson who is
he play he plays the Adam Sandler cat no
the Jack Nicholson character he plays
the counselor with the anger management
problems okay it'll start airing next
summer and begin filming early next year
only 10 episodes have been ordered but
they say if it proves to be a hit then
the next level is 90 episode order for
this show oh my god you could make a
quit on a month yeah so they're gonna go
from like one season to like ten seasons
yes that's okay the good news is I've
got Direct TV so I probably won't be
able to watch it it's the first time I'm
happy that FX may not be on my DirecTV
more horrible news this week the coroner
finally announced what killed Amy
Winehouse shockingly she died from
drinking too much I know it's hard to
believe yet so she had a blood level
alcohol five times over the legal drunk
driving limit they finally recognized it
was something like the legal limit is
like 800 milligrams
400 milliliters of blood and j-hat like
[ __ ] 408 years yeah ridiculous if
they had to tap her body to get her
blood up that's how much booze there was
sad thing is she had like quit drinking
for like three weeks or something like
that yes so when she kind of picked it
up again she went back to her previous
level and that might have just that's
why the moral story is don't ever quit
drinking and the Brits are the best two
of the official cause of death written
on her death certificate death by
misadventure oh I love the Brits oh that
sound wonderful doesn't sound so bad
when they write that on your death
certificate
sounds like a Winnie the Pooh story
that's right we approved the death by
misadventure Oh death by misadventure
telling she stubbed your toe and then
she died misadventure Michael Jackson
congratulations well he's still dead but
he is the number one earning dead
celebrity according to Forbes magazine
this week I saw no lie in the costume
store I wanted to do eyes on Sunset they
had six different Michael Jackson
costumes I was bought the one with the
propofol drip came with an IV stand that
you rolled around but they were out
Michael Jackson earned a hundred and
seventy million dollars in the past 12
months and he hasn't even been here no
he hasn't
here's the rest of the list the top five
at least Presley Elvis Presley was
number two made fifty five million
Marilyn Monroe was third with 27 million
dollars that stuns me I bet most people
haven't even seen a Marilyn Monroe movie
yet they're still spending 27 million
dollars on Oh where's that dead lady
Charlie Brown artist Charles Schultz 25
million dollars and then faith was a tie
between Elizabeth Taylor and John Lennon
with 12 million dollars each Lennon's
gotta be pissed this is such a [ __ ]
like even in death they still rank you
and make your race people how much you
may still a competition even when you're
done horrifying news in celebrity sick
bay this week Andy Rooney from 60
minutes is in serious condition in the
hospital this week
only had some minor surgery he was
having an eyebrow ectomy and things went
horribly wrong they won't give any more
details but apparently he is resting
comfortably but it's just three weeks
after he announced his retirement that
he's very sick proving once again just
never quit your job that's right I at
the job and don't stop drinking that's
rule one and then don't quit your job
you ever notice when people retire they
die shortly afterwards and that was the
last moment with Andy Rooney more
celebrity sick by new Steven Tyler from
Aerosmith was in a horrible accident
this week he was in Paraguay when he
slipped and fell in his hotel shower and
knocked two of his teeth out oh [ __ ]
that wasn't the bad news the bad news
was he had to go through four hours of
emergency dental surgery in Paraguay
which is done by the guy in the back of
a panel van gives you a bottle to heal
and goes acting with a chisel and a
chainsaw I got a picture of Tyler here
here's what he looked like after after
the accident he looks exactly like a
[ __ ] hooker I picked up on sunset one
looks like a [ __ ] myth or a little bit
like tip tooth roots a lot of it it's
like the weight has come off it's the
next morning got stitches over his eye
and he's missing a tooth I'm pretty sure
I saw him buy this taco stand over on
Santa Monica he still earned his under
dollars and pee-wee Herman says he'd
like to be on the next edition of
Dancing with the Stars that I would pay
cash money to see only if he dances on
the bar ballroom and said he would like
to compete because David Arquette's his
friend he's been supporting him in the
audience and he likes what he sees and
he wants to be on the next edition of
Dancing with the Stars I thought he was
like I want to dance no he wants to
dance with someone else on the show I
think it'd be awesome I've never watched
does that show pretty much what the
title says I've never noticed either but
I would watch a pee-wee Herman was on it
that's for sure
the certs of Scientology came out this
week that they have investigated South
Park creators Matt Stone and Trey Parker
this is sort of an evil story they did
you may remember back in 2005 that sound
Scientology episode felt trapped in the
closet where Tom Cruise refused to come
out of the closet it was an actual
closet he just wouldn't come out of it
and so the Scientology folks did not
take kindly to that one of their former
members who now has become a
whistleblower says that in fact he
showed documents to the Village Voice
that they actually went through their
trash looking for dirt on them that they
could use against them at some point
how weird it's spooky phone records bank
records personal letters that go through
your trash to find out what kind of
prescriptions you're taking and what
kind of alcohol you're drinking and how
much they can learn a lot from your
trash says this guy who was a former
member because all they've learned from
my treasures like this guy jerks off oh
wow look at all these paper towels in
this garbage but you're just tells you
wanted to piss me off they would just
stop Jack Daniels from manufacturing and
they let go through my trash just fine
empty bottle after empty bottle Michael
Owen is not a good person
he had a [ __ ] up week he was arrested
earlier this week I guess it was Tuesday
morning for violating a restraining
order against his girlfriend cops say
that he is not supposed to go near this
ex-girlfriend Kate major but he did and
she alleges that Michael pushed her
multiple times squeezed her arms and
threatened to throw her off a fourth
floor balcony
hey I must throw you off the balcony I
said I want to reenact it in case
anybody Thanks what am i following
closely enough cops showed up took him
into custody the judge in the case asked
Michael's lawyer does Michael know how
to read because apparently he violated
the restraining order was specifically
said he wasn't supposed to contact her
in any way right set bail for $5,000 he
was released on bail what did he do the
first thing out make a threatening phone
call to Kate major his ex-girlfriend
[ __ ] out of
on Wednesday he was arrested again cops
went to her house and he called while
they were there and she put it on
speakerphone the cops heard him
threatening her and went right to his
motel where he was staying at the
tahitian in which is a lovely place in
Tampa if you're ever there make sure you
check it out
when they showed up he saw them coming
and jumped off of a third-floor balcony
trying to escape from them
third broke his foot Lindsey's like yes
I'm not the most fucked-up one of my
family so he throw her off of a fourth
floor balcony he jumps off of a third I
guess he was just seeing if she could
survive or not for the next time poetic
justice
his daughter Lindsay however also had a
very interesting week she's always in
the news that's why we give her her own
theme song live
[Music]
why don't you come to your senses
Lindsay made some money this week she's
actually earning for a change it came
from Hugh Hefner playboy paid her nearly
1 million dollars to do a nude photo
spread this week
apparently Lindsay wanted a million they
offered 750 they met somewhere in the
middle by adding an 8-ball she already
shot the shoot and according to her mom
and sister she looks great in it that's
[ __ ] creepy oh to know level that mom
and sister sit around watching or take
new to photographs this family is the
model American family yeah father mother
children don't we have that picture the
picture of Lindsay naked [ __ ] hooker
picture yeah we don't need that
Lindsay actually was very productive
this week not only did she pose for news
photographs but she also did her
community service time at the morgue
which I thought was nice they could have
combined the two no they've been hot her
draped over the autopsy table it's sexy
yeah Lindsay her genitals are a gold
mine apparently this week because she
was also received an order from the
fleshlight folks hey they offered her a
million dollars that they could take a
mold of her bagina to make Lindsay Lohan
sex toys out of and she said no why why
would you hold out her representatives
say she would never accept such an offer
for any amount of money wait a min how
much was that again they had no she said
the Playboy she was tasteful but this is
not tasteful why isn't it tasteful I
don't know but flesh-like said labour
into it
flesh as I said that's cool most people
have had the real thing anyway so at all
how many gonna sell really I tried to
talk my wife into doing a man because
they were sponsors on SModcast for like
a year and I was just like you know I'd
[ __ ] a lot of flesh lights but I'd be
better if I [ __ ] the one that was
molded off of you and we could sell it
what do you think and she didn't talk to
me for two days I can imagine the only
flesh like what I want to [ __ ] is the
one based on your [ __ ] deer and she was
just like why the [ __ ] did I marry you
man that's repugnant I don't think so I
think it's kind of sweet I'm like I
don't want to cheat with some random
[ __ ] like cuz they take you know porn
stars and mold their [ __ ] up and so
instead you could get one that's just
not really it's just a whole yeah and I
went with that because I felt like using
somebody's vagina was cheating on my
wife and so I was like let's get one
made of you yes and she was like and you
would use it knows again anybody else -
it'd be kind of fun she didn't see it
that way
I wonder if they'd offered her a million
bucks that she would have done it though
at that point I would've been like oh
you're doing it she would have been a
few like 9 they're a [ __ ] play-doh in
the night and [ __ ] play-doh ogum
whatever it takes to get that mold man
at the fuzzy pumper barber shop I would
be describing it to where those court
people might [ __ ] it in detail so they
can draw something and then create a
mold off their artist rendering of her
vagina what if I was like silly play
remember like commercial for silly putty
when we were kids was and this was
imagine this is the days before the
[ __ ] Internet yes this was enough to
capture the attention and imagination of
a child
silly putty they showed a kid take it to
a comic strip from newspaper right which
if you don't know what that is a
newspaper so they put the silly putty
down and then it's you know squish it
and then pull it up slowly and the ink
from the newspaper would be on the silly
silly putty right then you could stretch
the image and make it look all goofy so
you can make Beetle Bailey look even
thinner yeah it was fun four minutes it
really was
and that commercial is enough to like
get kids to be like you gotta get [ __ ]
jelly buddy so you would put silly putty
on your wife's vagina make an imprint on
ya and make a little copy and [ __ ] and
get with the fleshlight then you can
stretch it make it look all weird and
stuff that's my wife's [ __ ] oh sorry
about that yeah nothing says love like
making a replica of your wife's [ __ ]
into what looks like a flashlight made
out of rubber I also offer them to make
since they were spot smart care sponsors
we offered to do thus mouths and they
were like what's that I'm like it's a
mold of my mouth and Scott motors mouth
would want to put their dick I don't
know but that'd be kind of fun you know
asides you bat well there's that of
course but I mean just the notion of
like put it out there and see which
one's sold better like whose mouth that
people want to [ __ ] more me as that
never happened but we can dream we can
do it I'm BAP I'd rather not thanks so
much I'm afraid I'd win while we're
talking about talentless [ __ ] Kim
Kardashian's in the news again
she has announced it's funny because the
actual casting was announced today but
she has left France know that she wants
to play Lara Croft in the next Tomb
Raider movie apparently she was so
serious about it that she wanted to pony
up the cash and produce the film herself
in order to star but they have announced
today apparently that Olivia Wilde is
gonna be the next Lara Croft Tomb Raider
and I know once again we've run into
this every episode no idea who Olivia
Wilde is that well when you see two
Raider you'll figure it out but yeah Kim
Kardashian also celebrated her birthday
in Las Vegas this week this is this is
the [ __ ] up [ __ ] with these people is
that they get to go and have a birthday
party in Vegas but if you and I went to
celebrate we would cash you know we pay
out some cash yeah privilege they paid
her to come to this marquee nightclub at
the Cosmopolitan Hotel and Casino they
paid her to come and have her birthday
party there Kim Kardashian Kim Carnell
what birthdays she was 30 31 years old I
think and so they paid her to have the
party there yes amazing the best part of
the story is though when she was
announced and came out onto the floor
everyone in the nightclub booed her
No yeah first day they booed her as she
was announced happy Oh badly she show up
and boom well I think they were there
anyway and then when they announced that
it was going to be a celebration for Kim
a lot of people it's a very hot it's a
very it's a brand-new casino so
apparently it's a very hot nightclub so
a lot of people didn't even know that it
was going to be her event so when she
was announced they were unhappy with the
fact now Chloe her sister apparently was
very upset took the microphone and tried
to defend her and then the booing got
even worse
Kim is so protective a suti Chloe is so
protective of Kim that apparently she
grabbed her snatch drop and then climbed
the replica of the Empire State Building
at New York New York and that was
patting down planes as they came flying
down to try to rescue her was beauty
that killed the basic beauties and
beasts also in the news I told you it's
all horrified we saw a picture of that
girl of Chloe yeah she's she's fun she
is kind of looking yeah actually sitting
next to Kim and Kourtney the other two
yet one of these things
like the others she was in the shallow
end of the gene pool to speak of
beauties and Beast Courtney Stodden you
remember her she was the 16 year old
girl who married the 51 year old actor
Doug Hutchinson oh my god from lost and
from the Green Mile they are still in
the news she is now 17 years old so it's
not nearly as creepy right for a 51 year
old to be Mary almost a woman that's
Rango
they were looking for pumpkins at a
pumpkin patch to celebrate Halloween and
they were in Santa Clara outside Los
Angeles here and well they weren't so
much looking for pumpkins as they were
doing a lewd photo shoot and there were
families there with kids that started to
complain about how disgusting they were
and so eventually security had to come
up and throw them out of the pumpkin
patch that's a first like I do first
people have ever been like will you
please leave the pumpkin pan you are to
disgust
to look for pumpkins please leave I
brought you some of the photos that were
taken at the pumpkin patch this is a
Cortney showing off her 17-year old ass
at the pumpkin patch apparently they
started dry-humping over the pumpkins
her 51 year old husband and it's when
they started really going at it and
making out around the kids that people
got freaked out and they were asked to
leave and was somebody following them
with a camera
oh yeah photo she brought a photographer
with them so they could shoot these
photos in the pumpkin patch will you
please leave sir why we're in love
Cortney tweeted after the event have a
beautiful blessed Sunday do not judge by
appearances but judge with right
judgment John 7:24 she quoted from the
Bible how she's one of these Christian
kids well kind of before this event she
tweeted ready to hit the hot and heavy
hay this afternoon yeehaw
love your all-american girls so she's
one of these Christian kids likes to
[ __ ] yes she is
gratulations the Ricky Martin his career
is getting to come back he's announced
that he's going to be performing on
Broadway starting next April they're
doing a revival of the classic Broadway
show Evita and Ricky Martin will be
starring in it as Che Guevara apparently
he is making a comeback due to the fact
that Ricky has joined the cast they've
changed the name to live in a vida loca
or maybe they haven't take that back
Jennifer Lopez in the news your old
buddy Jennifer I know her this story's
hysterical she was performing at an
Indian casino in Connecticut and the
prayin Sun the Mohegan Sun I've been
there you've been to the Hagin Sun yeah
I went looking for a poker table like we
ain't got any I was like [ __ ] I drove
three hours
that's my Mohegan Sun story
in a poker table not weird that's weird
for a casino not to have a poker table
they didn't do they like that's the one
game we don't play I was like this the
only game I want to play like you're
[ __ ] out of luck
not a great story but you know relevant
and as much as it happened where this
happened I guess I would have given them
some blanket with smallpox honor there's
something I would have sold that
Manhattan or something you know 24 bucks
you know get some revenge she was
performing and she has a bit in her show
I [ __ ] you not where she does a song
called until it beats know more about
love and behind her comes out a Jennifer
Lopez look-alike dancer and she goes
through a series of dance moves with
look-alikes from her past relationships
so a P Diddy look-alike comes out and
they do a dance number and then but of
but she does he's singing and they're
dancing behind her so there's a fake her
and a fake titties right okay imagine if
you were onstage performing and a guy
who looked just like you was performing
next to you it would be like that right
imagine how weird that was strange right
all right oh my god that'd be amazing
and if the show was like we're
podcasting right and then a seer like
there's you know someone else looking
like me right an interpretive dance of
the podcast right the podcasts about all
my failed relationships right so one by
one people that look like chicks I've
dated but nobody knows right it would
come up on stand I would start writhing
with them and dancing with them yeah I'm
so into that show
oh my god that'd be amazing so this is
what's happening I mean so she's singing
she's singing performing for the
audience behind her a Jennifer Lopez
look-alike is dancing with a P Diddy
look-alike
and then there's a transition and she
starts dancing with a Ben Affleck
look-alike and then she starts dancing
with a Marc Anthony look-alike
so she's just like these are the three
dudes I've [ __ ] yes
while she's singing about love she's
showing her past relationship okay fair
enough fair enough whatever she's a
performer and the poor the poor Marc
Anthony like they had to get him out of
a hospice to get him up on stage yeah
but that was that was sad he was running
around the stage going my precious well
apparently she was so moved by their
performance that she got choked up on
stage and started to cry oh no because
you know her her marriages failed so
that would be like back in our podcast
example I look over and see you [ __ ]
dancing with like the girl I dated in
high school right don't roll in the tear
exactly and the audience went crazy
because she got so choked up with
emotion crazy what started killing each
other
no they reached out with her with love
and support because they felt so bad
that their Idol was going through a
tough moment get out there
we made it real oh she was real [ __ ] got
real and and and because I think was
total [ __ ] I brought the clip in for
you to look at this is her faking being
choked up on stage at the Mohegan Sun I
hope you'll enjoy
[Applause]
we barely go on
what is the way what is that what she's
saying you said there's love right and
then there's love and then there's love
and then there's love and then there's
love and that's that what she meant the
love that the audience was giving her in
the moment was love or the fake versions
of her dancing with fake Benedick like
we're love I think it was someone showed
her the check for the night's box-office
in the back of the back of the stage and
she said that's what she loves Michele
Williams is playing Marilyn Monroe in a
new movie called My Week With Marilyn
this is a scary story she said that she
has received the ultimate credit for her
performances Marilyn Monroe you and I
should go play the Mohegan Sun we elect
the Mohegan Sun go how come her why not
us we can go play there no we can't good
look I don't want an image of you
wouldn't be look-alikes dancing behind
us while we're doing comedy amazing
we're in the middle of podcasts and some
guy in a leather jacket comes out
drinking Jack Daniels humping you and
behind us I don't want that Michelle
Williams plays Marilyn Rowe in this new
movie and she claims that is what why do
so many actresses like to play Marilyn
Monroe because she was she was [ __ ] up
like that so that's it it's just like I
get to show how [ __ ] she's an icon and
she's she was emotionally challenged and
they get to break down and and and [ __ ]
the president so they've got that going
for him she said while she was filming a
psychic told her that she had spoken
with the real Marilyn in the beyond and
Marilyn approved her her performance and
Michelle Williams was like you're crazy
no she said I'm glad she liked it she
thought I was doing a really good job so
maybe she likes it Michelle said Marilyn
reportedly liked her so much she sent
her a bottle of prescriptions and said
she assumed Daniel Craig's gonna be
James Bond again in the movie that
they're calling Skyfall which is a
horrible name for a James Bond movie
he is announced that he is going to be
the first James Bond with a beard he's
growing a beard for the role okay
you should give him some tips I'm gonna
say some people say he's had a beard for
years if you know what I'm saying I'm
kidding that's what Sean Connery says
about him did you see him in those
shorts coming out of the sea
double-o seven inches it looked like to
me Bond fans say Pierce Brosnan had a
beard but that's wouldn't he was he was
a captive in that movie and he didn't
have any choice this would be the first
bond with a beard so people history a
lot of conference drew upset they're
upset by the fact that bond will have a
beard because he's never had a beard
before he suppose to be clean-shaven I
mean he's actually technically supposed
to have a scar across his face as well
if you read the original Ian Fleming
books you know well he's got a scar
I heard originally supposed to be
hermaphrodite he's opposed to have
vagina and testicles would be so [ __ ]
hot could you imagine he's just like cuz
in those movies he's always that gets
the job done and then [ __ ] the chick
yeah and then and the movies now he'd
get the job done and [ __ ] himself you
know have the old ones is always like Mr
Bond we're trying to get bond on the
[ __ ] satellite M and they get him not
in tuned in and he's like in bed in
space with some chick like that was
Moonraker that was the end of for your
eyes only the end of all these movies
they catch him [ __ ] a chicken yeah Oh
James but if he was ever a Fredette the
end of those movies is way different
because they're not trying to get him
going
oh god James they're going like quite
quite watch the Tim bent over awkwardly
he's like putting himself inside himself
he's like what it's hard it won't bend
but what is soft it won't reach
nobody does me better steven spielberg
through George Lucas under the bus this
week finally really yeah I'm finally
stepped out was just like he did an
interview where he said that the the
aliens in the Crystal Skull the Indiana
Jones of the Crystal Skull that was all
George's idea he said I sympathize with
those who didn't like the MacGuffin he
says which refers to a plot point that
really is kind of meaningless in a in a
storyline because I never liked the
MacGuffin George and I had big arguments
about the MacGuffin
all right stop saying MacGuffin Steven
yeah I didn't want these things to be
aliens or interdimensional beings but I
am a loyal to my I am loyal to my best
friend when he writes the story he
believes in even if I don't believe it
I'm gonna shoot the movie the way George
and vision did don't don't do that again
Steven Spielberg he did say it was his
fault though for the fact that Indiana
Jones climbed inside a refrigerator to
escape a nuclear bomb he may remember
that scene in the film which is well
which were you more offended by him in
the fridge or him a new [ __ ] aliens
really yeah yeah I mean I'm bothered by
the fridge I wasn't offended by their
cuz it's a [ __ ] movie you know it
offends me like hunger you know if I can
say like a homelessness that [ __ ] I was
just like what a dumb idea then I moved
on Spielberg says blame me don't blame
George that was my silly idea regarding
the refrigerator people stopped saying
jump the shark and now they say nuke the
fridge I'm proud of that I'm glad I was
able to bring that into popular culture
he said but they don't they don't say
that no or they just say oh remember
what Spielberg was good and more
horrible news this week an Egyptian
mummy attacked a woman in Qatar this
week that Egyptian mummy was actor Omar
Sharif oh I don't know if you know who
Omar Sharif is but he was in a movie
many years ago was it was a big epic
film one old ton of Oscars for dr.
Zhivago
he was also in Lawrence of Arabia he was
a big heartthrob back in the 60s worthy
good-looking Egyptian actor and he was
known as quite the heartthrob he's older
now he's 79 years old he was at a film
festival in Qatar this week and he's
posing for some press photographs and
the photographers wanted shots of him
alone well unfortunately some woman
didn't understand that and she
approached him and he was angry at her
and I brought in a little video clip of
what happened after the fact that it's
it's very disturbing but it's kind of
funny too here you go so she asked for a
photograph
so just a warning for those of you who
line up over here forget t-shirts sign
after the show if I'm in a bad mood I
[ __ ] slap you right across the face
this is gonna give you the Sherif he was
an Oscar nominee for God's sakes geek
news every week we take a look at all
things geek keV and I are both geeks and
we like to talk about it James
[Applause]
[Music]
last week we talked about the fact that
mark hamill announced he wasn't going to
do the voice of the Joker any longer
yeah that was a bummer
he lied he came out this week and said I
just wanted to clarify that my Joker
comments are not related to Arkham City
so if they do another sequel to that
video game he said he would be willing
to voice the Joker again okay then a fan
said what if they were going to do an
animated adaptation of the classic Alan
Moore Brian Bolland novel The Killing
Joke the famous Joker comic book he said
oh I'd come back for that so apparently
he's gonna come back what do you got is
what he's saying basically I'm not going
to do the Joker tomorrow unless you
offer it to me and then I'll be back
also in geek news we talked about this a
little bit earlier Justin Bieber was in
the news this week he was pulled over by
cops in his battle AK apparently justin
was cruising with his three friends he
was in his battle AK and his friends
were in a Range Rover and a black
rolls-royce let me guess
Aquaman Superman Greenland that's right
and they cut off a CHP officer
so the CHP officer pulls the whole
Caravan over and of course beeps being
beeps he got off with a warning that's
it yeah that'd have been you and me we'd
be doing a hard time right now the worst
part of it is that he's taken a
perfectly good Cadillac and transformed
it into a half-assed Batmobile
they had photos of it on line this week
but here's the best part of the story
and the reason I bring this up is
because we're the radio station where I
do my morning radio show we share a
facility with a top 40 radio station
across the hallway and so this week
while I was calling Justin Bieber all
kinds of nasty names for having this car
turns out he was in the hallway on his
way to the other radio station and he
was walking in the hallway we didn't
know he was there until about halfway
through the show right when we were
sitting there in between song versus we
saw him pass by the window so we stuck
our heads out and all we'd hear him say
to his giant black bodyguard was like
this is a rough morning bro
first of all you can't pull bro off
Justin Bieber and second of all your car
is embarrassing here's some photos of
the back battle AK this is Justin in
front of his car he's painted it flat
black like a stealth bomber this is the
bat-signal that he has put on the front
of it this is these are nice cars these
these Cadillacs buy it's right there
nobody can see it or not this is what
he's had written on the back trunk of
the Cadillac Batmobile see it's written
there in the back and then on the side
doors he's got his own logo he doesn't
have the Batman logo he's got the JB
logo on each door on either side no it
doesn't it looks like it looks like a
[ __ ] mobile is what it looks like yes
meaning it's lots of [ __ ] no that's not
my meaning at all just it needs to be
stopped
really by any means necessary Canada
we're calling on you death penalty for
Justin Bieber he's gonna run his clock
it'll be done in a matter of time he's
17 years old and he's got himself a
half-assed Batmobile let's see no I'd
have the real [ __ ] Batmobile that's
what I'd have I'd be cruising deep I
have Adam West next to me I'd be I would
for reals what would that sound I wonder
what that would sound like old shaman
pull into the drive through I'm feeling
a Big Mac attack and now doing Ralph's
you have to be Ralph talking to Adam
West shut up old man I'm driving now I
would never say that I've been or don't
the red lights I'm safe I'm a safe
driver
that's like getting some drag through
man that's right get that taste out of
your mouth
every week we like to end the show by
asking a musical question but maybe we
should give away the the the prizes for
costume before we show how do we do that
we look out in the audience and you pick
the best girl costume desk guy costume
when we give them we give them an
autographed box set of videos I wants to
give everyone a prize I know you do
what about the he pledged Ledger Joker
right here that's pretty impressive
don't say I dig man I dig let's make him
our guy let's just do [ __ ] crowded
kid yeah got that why what are you a new
age of the Cobra Kai is dressed like a
like a like a skeleton while he's
thinking but that's what he did he's got
the face vest
oh I see just whatever beating he didn't
say that lime while he was wearing that
maybe that's where I'm good if you doing
a mash-up but I'm all about respected
yeah totally so we'll give one of these
to the Joker and where's where's it
where's the girl over there we got a
girl someplace oh my God look at him
stand up wow those are my significant
costumes overall a [ __ ] man yeah you
guys definitely win all right why would
you waste that costume on this show this
is that in the black you should have sat
right up front place real all right
we'll give you guys a box hit we're
gonna sign these in a picture of that so
we can put it up on the page yeah that's
right man all right yep Kevin's freaking
out he's way too stoned for that costume
he'll be amazing to get high with
oogie-boogie just [ __ ] do that dance
and [ __ ] throw dice do boogie but let's
ask the musical question we ask every
week shall we Kevin just how big is Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] stringing that's that's
big of course you can go to nice and
[ __ ] calm if you'd like to post your own
how big is Liam Neeson's [ __ ] fact John
Maguire and Glasgow put that all
together for us we appreciate it
let's start Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
it's so big that his [ __ ] ring was
forged inside the fires of Mount Doom
and only there can it be destroyed Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big you had to hire
two men to lower themselves from the top
of it on a scaffold and clean it with
squeegees Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
when he went trick-or-treating as a
child he always had to be a kangaroo
walking backwards Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is
so big it has Express and local lanes so
you can pick your lane you want to go on
leave me says [ __ ] is so big
FedEx offers Express and overnight
deliveries from the head to his balls
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big even
Courtney Stodden isn't shy around it
that was the 700s and pumpkin pie she
has no shame say so I guess Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that even
vaginal sex is considered skull-fucking
[Laughter]
so big it is the 99% and we are the ones
with pentacle topic very well Neeson's
[ __ ] is so big after Tony Danza Saad he
no longer asked who's the boss that's it
that's reaching back that is what I
appreciate Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
you have to trick it into saying its
name backwards in order to send it back
to the fifth dimension the mix-up like
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big it will
soon be getting its own NHL expansion
team wonder what the name would be the
foreskin is this stiffies that's cute
let's make it the [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm put on
the spot Liam Neeson's [ __ ] and it's a
hockey team cocky Liam Neeson's cocky I
like it
the schmidtty schmidtty need to like you
go pubes fair enough
and lastly Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
that a country fairs he lies on his back
and people pay to hit his nuts with a
giant hammer in an attempt to ring the
bell at the top
ladies gentlemen you guys have a good
time tonight thank you for being here
with us on a very spooky edition of
Halloween boo boo on but that's all we
got for this week for now I'm Kevin
Smith I'm Kevin Smith I'm Ralph Garman
I'm sorry battle the [ __ ] on
[Music]
[Music]